We buy things for wildly different
reasons.
We buy things because they satisfy basic
needs like hunger or thirst.
Uh,
we,
we buy products because they make us
feel good.
They meet our needs of identity or,
or needs of belonging,
right?
On some level though we buy everything
because it meets some needs that we
have.
And I think companies have kind of
gotten a shy about the reasons why
people buy their products.
The biggest myth I have heard in
corporate America is the myth of the low
interest category.
You'll go into a company that makes
widgets and they'll say,
oh,
well it's a relatively low interest
category.
It's something that people aren't that
interested in.
And so,
well,
our biggest,
you know,
our only choice is to just slice it down
and make it as cheaply as possible.
I don't think that's true.
I don't think there is any such thing as
a low interest category.
Every time we go in.
And,
you know,
we study cleaning products when we find
out that it's really about a mom caring
for her children and we study,
um,
soft drinks and we realize it's much
more about kind of feeling like you have
a sense of identity and belonging with,
you know,
with a group of people.
Um,
we study in engineering thermal plastics
and we discover that it's really about
chemical engineers who use those
thermoplastics feeling like they're
competent in their job.
There's always a human being in a high
interest factor associated with it.
I,
I've told more than one,
uh,
you know,
ceo that the first thing he needed to do
was to walk around his company and ask
people,
do you think we have a low interest
product?
Okay,
you're fired.
Right?
And get rid of people who don't believe
that the stuff that you may can change
the world because it is changing the
world whether they're noticing
or not.